so many grave whack packers we do you
know i might put together the whack pack
hall of fame beetlejuice it's fair to
say is the tom brady of the wack pack i
mean no questions asked
the goat
the greatest of all time ralph wants to
make a statement go ahead ralph i gotta
correct you here i heard you two crazy
people say that beetle was the greatest
of all time i said it robin said it i
happen to think that i know what you're
gonna say eric the actor i think eric
the actor was the greatest of all time
too absolutely iconic listen this is an
argument that's been going on a long
time it's like the beatles versus the
rolling stones it's hard to answer but
i'm just saying i loved eric the actor
but beetle was just a font of of content
what happened jd agrees with robin he
says
jd says beet is better than eric how do
you figure listen i love as
annoying as eric could be sometimes i
loved eric but yeah i was just great
about him
cuz
team uh beetlejuice was
like himself all
natural you got what you
uh you got what you want whatever he was
natural all the time
eric i think he had some sticks
sometimes can i rebut go ahead that's
ridiculous logic that is ridiculous
logic first of all it'll never quit the
show
listen jackass that's how you call a guy
who's worried about you you call him
jackass i'm black back here to tell you
to shove your show up your [ __ ] ass
are you really not doing the show
anymore or are you gonna rethink that i
don't need this [ __ ] anymore what
happened to the sweet guy i used to know
goodbye for good goodbye for good we'll
see how long you last
that's the point eric the actor quit the
show and then called up disguising his
own voice
i mean come on and he thought he was
fooling us there is a guy named derek
who's been calling
claiming he's not eric the actor
you decide how's that
hello sir
yeah i'm here
you claim your name is derek and you're
not eric the actor
you got that right
eric was not a contrived human being i
mean no no i'm not saying i'm not saying
eric when he called up when he
just think of it this way when he called
up johnny frato and said listen johnny
some guy's making fun of me i need you
to bump him off but he said you know
what to do you know giving him orders
like like the godfather
hey johnny did you catch the replays
doing it
dumbass call
and
find that guy
his name is gary you know what to do
you know what to do
just find them
come on man that that that was crazy and
then we would say to him you gotta fly
with balloons and then he'd go no i'm
not flying with balloons i go well i can
introduce you to kelly clarkson and then
he goes the biggest star in the room
when he came into the room he didn't
even care if another big star was in the
room they didn't mean anything to him
david spade is a big fan of yours this
is david spade
what's up buddy he's a big fan of yours
yeah he is he wanted to meet you
baba bowie agrees with uh jd and rob and
he says beedle wins and he has a
specific reason why is beadle the
greatest of all time okay first of all
the outfits alone were great you know
the beatle is don king his uncle stan
those are amazing beetles greatest
outfit this is tough i i know mine i
don't mind i think i know
what is uh whenever he was going up
against
no whenever he was going up against uh
gary the conqueror in that contest
he had that goofy like nerdy outfit and
it was big glass sparkle he played
article yeah he came in his circle i'm
with ralph i think maybe the superman
outfit that was the best when he walked
in a super beetle
i'll bet you any amount of money that if
i said to south now sal spent a lot of
time with beetlejuice on the road
because sal used to do some shows with
him
and uh i bet you sal would say
beetlejuice was the greatest of all time
too he'd probably agree with you guys
and not with me and ralph you know sal
hands down head and shoulders above
every whack packer beetlejuice
now i know why i'll tell you one great
story sal once told me sal was on the
road with beetlejuice right so sal had
this idea says hey let me take the
little guy out for a nice dinner and he
took him out for chinese food so sal
sitting at the chinese restaurant with
beetlejuice
and sal says to be
beat you're going to be excited you know
i wanted to get him the best thing on
the menu says i'm getting the dragon
chicken and beet turns to salad goes nah
i don't eat dragon
right that was the best
without missing a beat he's like yeah i
don't need dragons
me i don't need dragon
and he wouldn't eat it right he wouldn't
eat dragon
beetle would headline
every show like he was the biggest
attraction at these shows and iron sheik
used to get so jealous
of beetle he'd be like i [ __ ]
wrestled hulk hogan in madison square
garden and now i got to open up for this
[ __ ] and they used to they used
to fight hey sheik
will you ever share a room with beedle
again never ever again i'm gonna stop it
yeah
yeah he says he'll never share a room
with you again well we next time
next time the guys say something to the
pizza
don't come running to meet you little
[ __ ]
did you help him out in a fight
yeah god was gonna be the dad that's why
i left his ass there yeah
that was gonna be the dance
what happened last time when a guy beat
your ass when he flicked your ass
yeah the guy flicked your ass you were
running like a little [ __ ]
you're making the case listen to all of
this that uh wow out of beetle i could
make the same case for eric beedle is a
natural if i just mention
the fact that you know we negotiated a
huge tv deal for eric the actor that
whole thing eric wanted to be on a tv
show johnny negotiated the deal
and eric was [ __ ] out of his mind
because he said he knows there are
werewolves and vampires in new mexico
and he wanted something written into his
writer that he'd be protected from
vampires and werewolves eric does not
want any contact with some of the
dangerous wildlife that inhabit that
region uh including black bears mountain
lions coyotes bobcats spiders werewolves
or any venomous snakes
let me alter that okay
you want to take out werewolves
well
done actually
wikipedia and there actually are
legitimately werewolves in
albuquerque with what
i mean come on that was such a beautiful
moment i mean
you don't get the same reaction to that
story that we just got
seven eight stories about beetle
remember fred used to play the drop and
eric hated it so he threatened he was
coming to new york to break fred's
fingers
fred you push that button one more time
i'm gonna fight in new york
what zero
point
zero i'll meet you at jfk
there's only one guy who knows
who is the greatest whack packer all
time who's that
fred if fred says it and it's the truth
fred who's better beetlejuice or eric
the actor and if fred says it didn't end
the discussion i seem to be outnumbered
here and everyone is very articulate
very very articulate in their reasons
why beetlejuice should be
however
the best whack packer is by far and away
sorry everyone with the exception of
howard and ralph
is eric the actress
eric the fred hartley listens to the
show
he's great in the superman outfit he's
great as dodd king eric brought his own
game
[ __ ] closed
better robin you used to have that cute
little statue of eric i would have it on
my desk even now i am a big fan of eric
the actor of course you are maybe there
have to be two goats maybe there is
maybe there's such a thing as two goats
that's right robin who knows